einer der teuersten sachen von der jeder
von uns schon mal mitbekommen hat die
aber die wenigsten von uns testen dürfen
12.500 meterhoch 950 km h schnell und
unendlich teuer natürlich rede ich vom
business klasse
[Musik]
vor einem jahr habe ich bereits einen 7
euro flug nach mallorca gefunden und
diesen stunt bezahlt auf diesem flug kam
er aber einen noch viel verrückter
gedanke wie viel fun sammeln wir wohl
alle über ein jahr ohne dass wir es
wirklich merken wie viel geld kommt
dabei rum und noch viel wichtiger ist es
vielleicht sogar möglich damit dem first
class flug zu bezahlen viel spaß mit
diesem video
natürlich habe ich damit angefangen erst
mal aufzuschreiben wie viel fand ich so
wirklich zurückbringen habe eine excel
tabelle gemacht und immer alles
eingetragen
und bevor ich jetzt sage wie viel ich
über ein jahr gesammelt habt ihr werdet
euch wo man ich habe mich auch sehr
gewundert ich trinke extrem viel von
diesem süßkram und deswegen haben wir
auf einen betrag von 481 euro von 16 und
dazu kommt ich bin in einem büro wo ich
alle zwei wochen dafür verantwortlich
bin getränke zu kaufen beziehungsweise
fand zurück zu bringen und das hier sind
die getränke der drei letzten wochen
außerdem habe ich angefangen ein
bisschen aktiver nachfahren zu gucken
den nicht liegen zu lassen und dann wenn
ich irgendwo etwas gesehen habe habe ich
mitgenommen und abgegeben natürlich
nicht immer aber wenn sie in die
situation gepasst hat habe ich das
gemacht aber natürlich habe ich in der
business class mit diesem outfit nichts
zu suchen und niemand wird mich dort
sehen wollen deswegen brauchen als
allererstes neues aus
[Musik]
und genau das ist mein outfit um in die
business klasse kommt ein wunderbares
auftritt das sich sonst niemals tragen
würde
besonders die aber extra für euch und
für die wissenschaft naja aber es fehlt
noch mal so
barrymore koffer ja ich bin auf
geschäftsreisen
das richtige auto des gefunden aber
natürlich brauchen wir noch einen punkte
in irgendeiner weise in unser budget
passt und bei dem es gleichzeitig eine
vernünftige business class gibt ihr
wisst dass wenn man mit rein jahr für
sieben euro in wohin fliegt dann gibt es
keine business class in der man
vernünftig abstellen kann wir brauchen
also einen langstreckenflug und es
trifft sich ganz gut denn ich muss
tatsächlich für eine kleine doku-serie
nach dubai also schauen wir ob wir da
auf einem flug 20 minuten später nun ja
was soll ich sagen ich habe tatsächlich
ein hin und rückflug zusammen für 461
euro gefunden das passt und wir fliegen
einmal a380 und einmal boeing 777 beide
haben eine business class die eine auf
dem hinflug sogar mit ziemlich krasse
bei der ist eine extra waage bei der
ersten dusche gibt also auf dem hinflug
in die business klasse kommen wir der
absolute traum und ansonsten auf dem
rückweg ist auch nun aber ich werde aber
natürlich nicht komplett unvorbereitet
einfach an dem flughafen fahren und das
machen deswegen probiert jetzt kontakt
zu einer flug begleitung aufzubauen im
besten fall einer der direkt bei
emirates ist die mir sagen kann mit dem
oder dem trägt könnte es klappen dass
die reinkommen ist also wenn du
vortäuscht das und das zu haben wenn du
im flugzeug erzählt dass du eigentlich
vielflieger bist auch keine ahnung das
soll die personen mit sagen und parallel
bei sternen ein sehr vertrauenswürdiges
blatt nach gelesen dass ein paar tricks
und kniffe gibt jeder von uns beachten
kann von denen ich auch schon den einen
oder anderen erfüllter später check-in
erhöhen chancen kein problem das kriegen
wir hin gut gekleidet sein
dann und flexibel sein sich irgendwas
gutes ausdenken wenn man beispielsweise
mit einem kollegen reich der schon
business class ticket hat dann zu sagen
hey wir müssen unbedingt business mäßig
was besprechen gibt es einen platz in
der nähe und so weiter es wird bei mir
nicht funktionieren aber da werde ich
mir schon irgendwas aus den fingern
saugen damit das klappt und dann
natürlich auch ein vernünftiges
gebührendes review aus dieser business
class zu machen der tag ist gekommen an
dem wir versuchen werden mit fand in die
business class zu kommen aber ich habe
mir natürlich eine rolex organisiert und
werde logischerweise natürlich nicht
normal fahren sondern in einem
lamborghini mit schon fünf
[Musik]
damit ist es offiziell ich bin auf dem
weg zum flieger und werde versuchen in
die business beziehungsweise in die
first class zu kommen es gibt nur ein
problem ich habe gerade noch mal
geschaut so weit ich das sehen konnte
war kein einziger business sitz mehr
frei das bedeutet es gibt quasi nur die
möglichkeit in die first class zu kommen
auf dem hinflug was ich für ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich halte aber ich habe
mein bestes geben und vielleicht gibt es
die möglichkeit dass die einen umsetzen
dass ich doch in die first class komme
ich probiere auf jeden fall alles
menschenmögliche es ist so weit kurz
bevor das boarding startet ich fühle
mich schon ziemlich um mit diesem outfit
und vor allem weil ich ja gleich quasi
versuchen werde mir was zuschlug an ich
weiß noch nicht ganz genau wie ich es
mache ich weiß auf jeden fall dass ich
probiere als einer der allerletzten
reinzugehen damit auch die krude
überblick darüber hat ob noch business
class oder ob noch irgendwelche plätze
frei sind an denen ich interessiert bin
und dann probiere ich denen die
situation so zu erklären wie es ist so
dass man vielleicht auch den witz daran
verstehen dass sich das mitmachen möchte
und warum ich das mache desto näher der
flug aber kommt desto mehr zwei völlig
anders das in irgendeiner weise
funktionieren kann das outfit passt aber
auf jeden fall ich bin gespannt
ich weiß noch nicht ob es jetzt klagen
soll man reingehen
fraktionen platz
ich bin noch vor dem abflug gebrochen
ich bin gebrochen der erste hat er nicht
gefragt habe hat mir unmissverständlich
klar gemacht das wird nichts wert
ich habe es aber natürlich nicht auf mir
sitzen lassen und einfach jede weitere
des jedem weiteren stört damit auf dem
flug bahn auch gefragt einige
stewardessen haben mir super freundlich
abgesagt andere deutlich weniger von
richtig glaube das ist so eine
standardfrage ist die man auf jedem flug
mehrmals zu hören bekommt die einfach
irgendwann zur halskrause
gerade kam dass die wir sehr sehr
wichtigen tipp gegeben hat anscheinend
kann die kabinen nichts entscheiden also
niemand kann einfach so ein upgrade gibt
in notfällen ist das anscheinend möglich
wenn jemand jetzt super krank ihr wenn
jemand auf einmal unbedingt liegen muss
dann ist es möglich aber ansonsten kann
die kabine kommt das nicht entscheiden
ich werde mir vor meinem rückzug also
zeit in dubai am flughafen nehmen und
probieren es am boden zu klären also am
boden zu emirates zu gehen und zu sagen
hey das und das so sieht's aus gibt es
irgendeine möglichkeit wie die business
class kommen kann weil sobald ich einmal
im flugzeug bin wird es nicht mehr geben
weil die stewardessen das einfach nicht
entscheiden hätte man sich vorher
vielleicht über informieren können habe
ich nicht gemacht lehrgeld bezahlt und
jetzt probiere ich das auf dem rückflug
einfach ein bisschen besser zu machen
schnell greifen
in dubai angekommen wurde ich direkt
weiter komplett hobbs genommen das video
das ich eigentlich geplant hatte hat
sich komplett in luft aufgelöst meine
kontaktperson ist nicht gekommen es war
einfach komplett schrecklich ich wusste
aber jetzt hängt alles an dem rückflug
jetzt muss ich alles dafür tun dass die
business class auf dem rückflug
irgendwie klappt
das ist quasi mein letzter versuch
zu meinem glück war die frau am schalter
aber super gut drauf hat sich meine
story angehört und hat mir dann
freundlich abgesagt ich dachte also es
wäre komplett vorbei ich habe meine
kamera hoch geholt die auf den tresen
abgelegt und auf einmal hat sich das
blatt so ein bisschen geändert die frau
hat angefangen so ein bisschen
nachzufragen ich habe erklärt dass sich
youtube finden und dass das ganze in
youtube experiment gewesen sein und dann
ist etwas passiert mit dem ich niemals
gerechnet die nette frau ist jetzt seit
15 minuten hinter diesem schalter
verschwunden und möchte mit ihrem chef
sprechen also sie ist mir eigentlich
ziemlich wohl gesonnen ich glaube aber
auch nur weil ich eine kamera dabei habt
ihr doch gefragt für welchen youtube
kanal und so weiter geht davon aus dass
sie jetzt gerade hinten drin sind und
einmal checken was ich so mache mit
einem kostenlosen upgrade was ich
einfach so bekommen habe weil ich super
nett war oder warum auch immer hat das
natürlich dann nichts mehr zu tun aber
nichtsdestotrotz hätte ich es irgendwie
in die business class geschafft das wäre
richtig krank ich warte jetzt darauf
dass sie wiederkommt und mir hoffentlich
wunderbaren nachrichten unterbreitet
wenn ja dann komplett
leer es ist so oft packen jack sock noch
gar nicht ich jetzt wahrscheinlich erst
checken wir nicht auf dem platz sitzen
oder das erste mal essen bekomme alles
ist wieder wirst du bittest funktioniert
hat es ist so fucking dumm
zu dem zeitpunkt konnte ich mich nicht
so richtig freuen auch jetzt konnte ich
mich noch nicht so richtig freuen ja ich
hatte ein ticket in die business class
aber das video hat halt nicht
funktioniert ich wollte es mit fand in
die business class schaffen und das hat
definitiv nicht geklappt
nichtsdestotrotz hat sich meine mut dann
doch wieder ein bisschen geändert als
sich die ersten schritte in die business
class lounge und ins flugzeug gesetzt
haben düster aussah was ist da an
besonderheiten gehabt wie mein flug war
und alles weitere seht ihr im kommenden
video am donnerstag in dem ich diese
komplett experience dann extra nochmal
riesengroß abgefilmt habe und bewertet
habe lohnt sich das diesen flug der
eigentlichen knapp 2000 euro kosten was
für vorteile hat man quasi wie ein hotel
test jetzt nächsten donnerstag also
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
das video zu liken und dann sehen wir
uns in ein paar tagen wieder kurs nicht
jedes video kann klappen diese lehre
ziehe ich aus diesem video
[Musik]